Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Bob.
Today I'm going to talk about the multis
language.
Maltese is a unique and interesting
language because it is a Semitic
language with a twist.
It is the only Semitic language that is
an official language of the European
Union.
It is spoken by around 520,000
people,
mostly on the island nation of Malta,
which is an island in the Mediterranean
Sea,
not far from Sicily and not far from
Tunisia and Libya in North Africa.
Some people claim that Maltese is a
descendant of the ancient Phoenician
language,
but actually there is no linguistic
evidence for this Maltese as a
descendant of a dialect of Arabic called
low Arabic or Sicilian Arabic,
but it has diverged quite a lot from
Arabic over the last thousand years or
so and has now become its own language.
The syntax and grammar of Maltese
remains Arabic and about a third of the
vocabulary is still Arabic and that
includes most of the grammatical
function words as well as a lot of the
most basic vocabulary.
About half of the vocabulary is from
Italian or Sicilian,
and the remaining vocabulary is mostly
from English and French.
It's still considered a Semitic language
because of its Arabic origin and because
of its structure,
but if you take into account all of the
foreign loan words,
especially the Romance Sloan words,
then it's essentially a hybrid language.
Kind of like a Semitic romance hybrid.
So how did this interesting mix of
influences come together to create
Maltese?
Well,
it's because of its history,
of course,
the fatigue,
mid caliphate,
which covered much of North Africa,
conquered Sicily at the end of the ninth
century and brought their grubby or
north African dialect of Arabic with
them.
Then in 10,
49 ce,
Arabic speaking Muslim settlers from
Sicily arrived in Malta,
which is only about 200 kilometers away
and began to establish communities.
They're in the year 10 91 ce.
The normans who were Christians from
Normandy and present a France,
had defeated the Arabs and taken hold of
Sicily,
and then began taking hold of multitude
under Norman rule.
More settlers from Sicily began arriving
in Malta and bringing their language
with them.
Even though the normans were Christian,
the population of Sicily was still a
mixture of Christians and Muslims who
spoke Arabic alongside the Sicilian
language.
After the decline of Norman rule,
the new regime in Sicily expelled all of
the Muslims from Sicily and from Malta
as well.
This was a very significant event
because it essentially cut off the low
Arabic dialect from the Muslim Arabic
speaking world,
and it also cut it off from the
classical Arabic language and other
Arabic speaking lands.
The Qur'an remains a conservative force
that prevented the dialects from
changing too much overtime,
but in Multa,
that conservative force was no longer
connected to the dialect,
so the dialect was free to drift off in
its own direction and become a new
language.
Seek low Arabic diet out in Sicily,
but it continued to be used and evolve.
In Malta,
Malta remained part of the Kingdom of
Sicily for several hundred years,
which brought lots of Sicilian
vocabulary into the language.
The island was controlled by a string of
rulers who influenced the developing
multis language.
One of the most significant regimes to
rule Malta was the knights hospitaller
of St John.
A powerful order of nights that assisted
in protected Christian pilgrims on their
way to the holy land.
They were given the island of Malta in
15 slash 30 as an outpost to help
prevent an automated invasion of Rome
from the south.
They made Italian the official language
of the island and it remained the
official language until 1934.
This resulted in a large amount of
Italian vocabulary entering the
language.
There was also a period of two years
when Melissa was under French rule and
just from those two years quite a bit of
French vocabulary entered the language
too and the island was a British
protectorate from 1800 to 1956.
And of course that led to the adoption
of lots of English words into Maltese.
So multis is essentially an Arabic
dialect that has become latinized and to
some extent anglicised.
So how similar is it to Arabic today?
Well,
if you know Arabic and you try to read
some Maltese,
you will quickly realize that it's
basically Arabic instructor,
but you will also see a lot of foreign
vocabulary.
Mostly romance vocabulary in it's most
similar to the mug.
Grab dialects of Arabic,
meaning the dialects of Morocco,
Algeria and Tunisia,
especially the Tunisian dialect.
A lot of Tunisians claim that they can
quite easily understand multis.
That could be because Tunisian Arabic
itself has quite a few Italian loan
words and I also understand that a lot
of Tunisians can understand standard
Italian,
so if they speak and Arabic and Italian
than they can quite easily understand
multis.
Lots of people say that if you know an
Arabic dialect quite well,
and if you also know Italian,
then reading Maltese won't be much of a
problem and with some adjustment you can
also learn to understand it fairly
easily.
That doesn't mean you could speak proper
Maltese,
but maybe you could use your Arabic,
endure Italian and sort of pack a
conversation in a new pigeon language.
So let's look at a couple examples.
Sentences of multis.
So this sentence here is an example of
one that's mostly Arabic.
By the way,
I've never learned to speak Maltese,
so forgive my pronunciation.
It'll Japa Nandua last populates.
That buck dot mia situ ushered in
million petta sooner.
Now I understood this sentence almost
perfectly,
and it's basically all Arabic.
Uh,
the first word,
illegit boone.
That's Japan on blue.
That's has a last shot.
That's the 10th.
That's the biggest pool.
That's the one that's not Arabic,
but that's,
that looks like an Italian lone word to
me type thing.
Yeah.
So that's in the world.
The appetite mean that means with more
of them.
And then there's the Arabic number,
mia said to ocean and then there's
mulloon which is million and Arabic too.
And then pepper summa,
which is not Arabic,
but I guess that's from Italian
Sicilian.
But sometimes you see sentences with a
lot more loan words,
particularly Italian.
Here's another sentence you form a field
of [inaudible] on that includes the
other printer.
Pewter Solid Arrietta.
So this sentence means migration reform
must include the principle of
solidarity.
This one has a lot of loan words.
The Pharma,
that's not an Arabic word,
that's alone word feeling bigger.
That sione field,
that part is Arabic,
but make it.
That's the one that is a long word under
that part is interesting because this is
an Arabic word that means has,
but in this case it's being used to mean
has to or must and it's not used that
way in Arabic,
so the function of this word has become
somewhat adapted in the multis language.
The next word included.
That's include but that the t links back
to the previous vowel and that's an
element of Arabic syntax.
The next word friendship you.
So that's obviously principal,
but that's not an Arabic word.
That's a long word.
And tests.
Solar Data Yetta.
Again,
that's the Arabic definite article and
the t is linking back to the previous
vowel and solid data yetta.
That's solidarity and that's not an
Arabic word either,
so you can see a lot of sentences like
this and Maltese.
Often if you have no Arabic you'll
recognize the structure,
but then a lot of the words are not
Arabic.
For me personally,
I know that with my past study of Arabic
and with my fluency in English and my
recent basic knowledge of Italian,
I can take a stab at reading multis and
I can understand a fair bit of it,
but not all of it.
When I hear spoken Maltese,
I don't really understand it,
but I can pick out some individual
Arabic and Italian and English words,
but I imagined that as my Italian
improves,
I'll be able to understand a bit more of
it and if I decided to review my Arabic
in depth and start to learn on my grubby
dialect,
then I think I would be able to
understand a lot more Maltese as well.
Maltese is not a very widely spoken
language,
so not that many people learn it and
there aren't that many materials out
there for learners,
but for someone who's learning Arabic or
learning Italian than it might be fun to
dabble in some multis and see what you
can make of it.
Thank you for watching the length focus
channel.
If you have any comments about the
multis language,
then of course leave them in the
comments down below.
If you're an Arabic speaker and you've
had a chance to listen to multis a
little bit,
let us know what you think.
Can you understand it?
Does it sound like a kind of Arabic?
And the same goes for Italian speakers.
If you listen to [inaudible],
can you catch parts of what they're
saying?
Let us know in the comments down below,
we're getting close to 50,000
subscribers on Lang Focus.
That's quite cool.
I'm quite excited about that,
but if I look at my social media
channels,
if I look at facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
I noticed that I still don't have that
many followers,
so be sure to have a look at those.
The link is in the description down
below and if you find them interesting,
then be sure to follow me there.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.